who's running for the Senate from the
state of Nevada and he joins us attorney
thanks so much for coming on
um is your opponent even willing to
acknowledge that the country is being
overturned by a surgeon violent crime
well it's definitely not a topic she
wants to focus on uh in fact she's
closing the race with John Legend who's
a known defund the policer that's about
the best she could do on the surrogate
tour and and the bottom line is uh she's
running away from her record every
single second of this race which is why
we've pulled ahead it's a tight race and
yeah they're spending almost 90 million
dollars and Counting now to defeat me uh
but but you know this is the 51st seat
the Democrats want to try to save her
but at the end of the day we had Las
Vegas Metro and Statewide police flip
from her to me typically they support
Democrats but they're fed up I mean they
want a former AG that is going to stand
with police through thick and thin like
you did during the BLM riots she was
nowhere to be found in fact she threw in
with them and said that she supported
BLM and cops were systemically racist
now of course she's doing her her
election year turn around and trying to
pretend that she supports the the police
but I could tell you when you talk to
cops in Nevada they're not buying it for
one second they know that only one
candidate is truly standing with police
and they know it's existential for them
we have to stand with our police we have
to get our communities cleaned up and
and this is why these races are swinging
our Direction I firmly believe yes it's
economy of course as well but Law and
Order and Border issues are a huge piece
why people are fed up and they want
something different and she's literally
spending her closing act with some
creepy Hollywood defund the policer is
anyone noticing this
no I mean nobody's covering it of course
we put out a press release in the media
of course ignored it uh nor and they
also won't cover the fact that Joe Biden
came out west skipped Nevada you think
that'd be a big deal right but he's at
37 percent and you know he went on TV
about a month ago and said what do you
mean defund the police we've always
supported the police uh but she wants
nothing to do with him even though she
supported him every step of the way
people laughed when you got into this
race there's no way you can win in the
state of Nevada which is democratic
State and but you are winning it's
amazing amazing story Adam Blackstone
congratulations thanks Adam
blackstone.com thanks subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight